i
was i wasn't going there until you
actually heard other accounts of it and
you thought oh maybe i should revisit
the stream maybe it was something that
happened
until i started looking into my own
experiences so after that experience in
the mountains with kristen
i saw a real owl i heard a voice in my
head that said this has something to do
with ufos
a message right so i got a message from
who knows where it was or it could have
been from my unconscious could have been
from the owls it could have been who
knows but i
definitely saw real owls and in my head
heard the booming
words this has something to do with ufos
and i
in 2006 really started looking into this
stuff so
it would have been after 2006 after that
event in the mountains with kristin or
those two events
that i started looking into these
experiences and started
um really
taking it seriously and looking into my
own experiences like now the question is
am i an abductee right given that given
these kind of experiences right this is
in an abductee is that that's a that's a
that's a lousy term right that's the
term we're stuck with that's an x-files
term
um and what i found in in the last
you know what is it 14 15 years of
research much of it feels like full-time
research
is that that's really common that
there's this
there's this elusive quality to it very
very there are some people who have like
concrete
memories boom i remember this event
right like travis walton's
you know yeah you met him many times
yeah oh wow yeah so he's a very nice guy
he's from the west i was living out west
he's a
he's a westerner there's like a kind of
stoic quiet soft-spoken
quality to the guy he is not the kind of
guy that exaggerates
right yeah so and here he recounts
everything up to the point of waking up
on a table seeing these beings in there
seeing like actual human looking things
in there
and then after that wakes up on the side
of a road he was gone for five days
and he has like 15 minutes of memory i'm
i haven't it's been a long time since
i've read the book so did he have any
experiences with owls when you talk to
him
i gotta be careful what i say because
he's some stuff he's told me
he's he said he'll never listen to this
don't worry
no but i want to be careful what i say
so you know what he was i was in a group
of people when he told me this
he he said now this doesn't mean much
but he said his son as a little baby as
a little child
they had a a big macrame kind of
embroidered owl
in the hallway really and he said his
son was terrified of that owl
that that embroidered all so like kind
of a simplistic image of a bird with big
black eyes
and so that's not much to go on but he
he was he was kind of like
he told me that and and he you could
tell he was
you know the wheels were turning in his
head that was his only i'll experience
that was
that's usually that's the only thing he
shared with me yeah and he's very
tight-lipped he'll say
like people ask him at conferences like
have you ever had any other experiences
and he'll say if i had another
experience i would tell
no one basically telling one experience
ruined my life
is where he's coming from ruined his
life
in the 70s and 80s and 90s but now it's
becoming
some sort of a more accepted thing in
modern culture i mean it's a thing that
every news
channel every blog website wants to talk
about because
you know now it's profitable now it
draws attention and draws clicks and
yeah and but it he's he if he given the
choice he never
would have chosen this right this in his
life
have you have you heard his story about
how he told he tells how he
wakes up in the middle of the night out
of nowhere and he's running full speed
down his hallway to his kid's room
and he says his kid is on a top bunk oh
no and he's he's uh his kid is like they
have the rails in the top bunk that sort
of like keep you from falling off
the kids his son had slipped off and he
had his neck wedged between
the railing and i guess he like grabbed
him and
and pulled him out and if you would have
stayed there for another 30 seconds he
would have been dead
so he has all these crazy little he has
multiple similar experiences i've heard
him talk about
like that that he can't explain so
so mufon is a very dry
you know what we then in the in the
litter in the research community there's
like nuts and bolts researchers
that's mufon mutual ufo network it's an
organization of ufo
researchers they are very nuts and bolts
and on the other end of the spectrum is
this kind of
consciousness love and light thing and
they do not mix
these two worlds now the very
conservative
mufon has a checklist you go to you go
to a ufo witness's house it's very this
kind of stuff what time what day
which direction was it going can you
draw a picture of it did you know
it's very scientific very well yeah it's
very analytical and
in that checklist they say ask the
witness
have you had any has your psychic
abilities changed since you're wit since
you're sighting
this is like the dry people this is like
and then you know like the people who
like
ain't going there they're not gonna and
it's right in there in the checklist is
any
have you developed any psychic abilities
and then also
has it has your spirituality or
religious have you
have you changed your spirituality or
religion since the event
and this that's so those questions are
kind of at the core of my research
and they're at the at the just a tiny
little sliver at
in the in the mainstream ufo witness i
would love to talk to those guys that
saw the
stuff off the aircraft carrier and you
know off the california coast and say
like
have you had any like any psychic
abilities what's going on weird
synchronicities
like why do they ask why do these nuts
and bolts type researchers ask them
about psychic
psychic experience because you know that
can kind of weed people out be like oh
this person's a psychic believer this
person's
we can dismiss them now i think it's
just the opposite i think what they're
seeing is a pattern
you talk to these people and they'll
still they want to talk your ear off
someone's taking them seriously a ufo
researcher comes to your house and tells
you
you get you're allowed to tell your
story without being ridiculed
right so that's so they'll say like and
all this weird stuff has happened since
my sighting
i've had psychic experiences so these
are this is what's common
after a sighting this isn't this isn't
aliens in the house this is just seeing
a ufo
off in the distance your psychic ability
increases
i'm generalizing greatly it doesn't
obviously doesn't happen 100 of time but
this is
a consistently reported stuff your
psychic abilities increase
your spirituality will change and
you will often be plagued with
synchronicities
like meaningful coincidences
and then um
poltergeist activity in the house
so how are like little aliens in a metal
spaceship making poltergeist activity in
the house happen
you know something else is going on that
takes it out of the realm
of you know aliens from another galaxy
visiting us on their metal spaceship
and puts it more into the realm of these
myth makers this ancient lore
of of something from that other realm
interacting with us
what do you think it is why do you think
that people who have these ufo
experiences
who have witnessed think who believe
they have witnessed ufos what what do
you think it is
that keeps them having these experiences
or different kinds of experiences what
do you think it sort of just like opens
up something in their mind where now
they're just always
looking for weird [ __ ] possibly
yeah so possibly that's one of the
problems with the ufo community is
because once you've seen this stuff and
once you've seen the weird [ __ ] like
you're open to everything and like let
me tell you like you're
it's like you got to be careful how open
that door gets because there's a lot of
people within the ufo community who are
primed to like believe in conspiracy
stuff and some of the nuttier
like fringier stuff that like i'm
looking for conspiracies i'm looking for
the weird stuff
and i have to be really careful not to
get dragged down these blind alleys
so yeah it's it it turns a people can
get very
vulnerable after these events you know
to cult leaders to
to um like losing their
critical thought right and i have i have
done my very best
like to like i try to present myself as
a credible person telling an incredible
story
or telling someone else oftentimes other
people's stories so i feel like i'm
hopefully remain credible in the way i
present the stuff
but i am presenting things that are
incredible and oftentimes beyond belief
now um your question was uh
what you know why are they open to the
psychic phenomena or
uh well the psychic question regarding
the uh the ufo researchers talking to
these people
oh yeah yeah asking about psychic
abilities or
psychic phenomenon to me that kind of my
first reaction to hearing that is like
okay let's see if this person believes
in psychics let's see if they believe
they have psychic abilities or let's
that that could be on par with saying
okay when's the last time you saw
bigfoot
yeah you know okay now we can just
dismiss this [ __ ] because he's
you know he just believes that he's some
chosen ufo
abductee and you know he's gonna believe
in every conspiracy that we put in front
of them
i think it came the other way around i
don't think they're trying to weed
people out i think it's a legitimate
question because what happens is
you talk to these people the witnesses
and they will say this weird thing
happened like like my psychic like
my psychic abilities like i feel like i
have become
i've i now have esp since seeing the ufo
um oftentimes people don't know how to
control it and it's just fleeting little
things can you give me an example of
some sort of psychic ability like this
um what would you consider psychic a
psychic
ability okay so here's the story this
woman this has an owl in it there's a
woman her name is maria wheatley she's a
crop circle researcher in england
and she was with a friend and they were
going to go hike up to the top of a
hilltop the hilltop is called
oliver's castle sometimes the hilltops
are called castle that's what they call
the hills there
so she is going to walk
uh up up to the hilltop and there's a
path excuse me there's a path in the
woods
that goes to the tail top and as they
walk down the path this owl a white
barn owl flies right in front of them
and both get the exact same sensation
the exact same feeling they say oh we're
not allowed in the woods
like it's barring our way so they turned
around and then they walked up a
different way
and you know through the meadows and
stuff like that but not up through the
forest and the trails
they get to the top of the hill and they
look off in the distance and there's
this orange
floating orb out in the distance like
what is that thing and then it and then
it gets closer and it grows big and it
grows into this big size of a giant
cigar and it's coming towards them and
then it ship shrinks and disappears
so they don't see a metal spaceship they
see this orange disruption of light
right so they run back to their car she
said he was shaking so hard he couldn't
get his car keys in the
in the car door and afterwards now
beyond just doing
um uh
the the cropsicle research maria
wheatley also does uh tarot reading
where she'll
you know read uh divination with a tarot
deck
she said her ability to do tarot
readings increased
exponentially she said it got really
high
and then it tapered down a little bit
but she is now she feels she is
she is much more mystically in tune with
doing tarot readings than she was before
seeing the orange orb in the sky the guy
to have gone to the bar to the pub and
he could read everyone's mind in the bar
you could see what everyone was thinking
and it freaked him out
it was not a good thing like he freaked
out and that eventually eased off
and so the this if you ask the questions
these are the stories that emerge
from these these kind of accounts these
mystical strange
stuff
i